um so as you know like it used to be
very traditional right like it used to
be very much like the women stayed home
the men were more providers um but as
like more women enter the workforce like
things change the development of birth
control also changed a lot of things
so um i'd like to go around and everyone
say
what
do you believe do you believe there
should be gender roles in 2022
in relationships could someone else go
first
i don't mind going first i think
that it i think a lot of it depends on
um
who the main bread owner is in the
relationship
and how much
that person earns as well mm-hmm if
you're both struggling if you're both
sort of average every journey you gotta
split things up make things work between
two of you but if one of you is like i
don't know a millionaire mm-hmm no one's
not you know you know no matter what
that one earns when it's not a
millionaire earns doesn't really matter
it's in the relationship so then
and i always also believe that whoever
is the main breadwinner has the sort of
um
they sort of dominate they they they
lead the relationship mm-hmm so the
other one
so you think whoever makes more should
like submit to the other basically like
this oh yeah yeah sorry sorry yes yes
and that's why things can be complicated
because okay we've believed that
normally it's men that earn more okay
when a woman earns more and normally
especially if she owns significantly
more than her partner then you're going
to probably find some issues in
relationship long term okay
um i'd say yeah i'd say i agree with
that as well but um
in a scenario because obviously back
back then it was very much like the
woman is the you know stay-at-home wife
and then obviously there was a lot of
development with like the females right
and all that stuff and now it's like
men but generally
earned more
but now because obviously like you said
gender equality and stuff um women can
earn
just as much if not more so it does kind
of like
put like um
a stop to the kind of like men earning
more and so that's something that's uh
type of thing
um
and yeah that's a that's about it from
okay i feel like
you should do like whatever you're good
at so if someone's good at cooking they
should just do that instead of trying to
push the gender roles let's say
the woman should cook even though the
man is like a chef i just find that kind
of stuff
oh yeah
yeah do what you're good at in the
relationship and make balance try and
make balance
i like that part yeah i like i think i
agree with the you know usually i i mean
i guess it's not it's just how it goes
usually whoever earns more the other
person usually submits because
i would say like you just feel like that
person is just
not like
over you are like bigger than you but
it's just it's just how it is but i also
do like that you know whatever you're
good at in the relationship like you
know just do it like
you know maybe the woman doesn't know
how to do laundry and the man's like you
know that's his thing yeah
maybe he loves like folding clothes it's
like a thing that keeps him like
being from the i'm i'm sorry being from
the male agenda
i don't know any man that would love
folding clothes i promise you that now
any man that does i'm sorry
[Laughter]
um okay so what do you think if they
make the same amount of money
i'd say there's like a 50 50 thing
okay um let's say like you know if there
is like a kid that's on the way maybe
and then i'm assuming like they would
like discuss who would be the one who's
like not like the main caretaker but the
one that like saves him take care of the
kid and then
the other one's like working to earn
money
but i don't think that there is any like
man or woman that should just be like
submitting to doing that i think there
has to be a discussion between the two
okay
i think it depends on your tax bracket
okay tax bracket yeah i think how much
you're earning yeah i think i think
both average earners if you both are not
earning 50 000 but yeah for example
that's not a great wage especially in
london it's just a struggling wage in
london and you've got to do things
together work out together but you're
both gonna have to work full-time right
so that makes things a bit difficult to
say well you should all you you should
do this i should do this because you're
both doing full-time work
if you're earning i know 250 grand each
then things become a bit easier because
then you can hire people to do things
for you yeah you have to worry about
who's cooking because you can got to eat
more often i can get someone to cook for
you mm-hmm you have to worry about it's
cleaning up because you can get leading
cleaner to get outside so the gender
roles stop a certain salary has become
i think
i think the general is
i don't
today's cycle no it's difficult it's
very difficult to have specific roles
um
what i would say is if one it is like i
said if you're both working
then
especially working full time i think the
role thing is a bit more tricky to work
out
um and
you guys both mentioned do we bestow
mm-hmm yeah if i'm with a partner now
we're both working and i'm a better cook
then
cook yeah yes cook so well sometimes
it's not like okay
but um if one of you likes to do what do
you what are you working that one isn't
yeah that's a completely different story
what if he's working and one's not then
what you're doing mm-hmm you should be
dropping all right that's true you gotta
put your you pull your weight in another
way what if one's like just like
naturally wealthy like they've inherited
their wealth and doesn't need to work
and one has to work like should that
person still work full-time it's like
one partner is like just wealthy like
from a wealthy family doesn't actually
need to go to work because i have that
wealth already and then someone would
should you make your partner go to work
but i think i mean if they already have
the wealth and then like they're just
like you know staying at the house they
might as well do like the stuff like you
know otherwise what are you doing just
sitting on your ass yeah while the other
person is like working their ass off and
like you know by the time they get home
then they're tired as hell yeah but i
was gonna say i was gonna build on the
first point that you made and i can in a
case of like
when when a man and a woman have like a
baby and let's see they are like average
you know they make average wage more or
less the same it should be 50 50. but
then the woman at the end of the day
still kind of gets an advantage so it's
not exactly legal because at the end of
the day you can talk about it but the
man's still going to go to work while
the woman stays at home for those nine
months or however many next month mom's
that day she can stay things like
buddies in uk it's like yeah i think
a year
about about a year right and she stays
at home and you know
it can be split between whether you can
choose who takes a year off whether it's
a man or a woman oh really
but now but naturally it's always the
woman yeah because more often than not
the man earns more women so it makes
more sense for her to be and also i mean
women here you're going to want to bond
with your children what have you yeah
and recover
what would you say for like after like
you know the kids like a toddler and
like you know
you can sometimes
again especially in london sometimes
sometimes it doesn't even make sense for
her to go back to work because she
literally just paints going to work to
fund child care
yeah the point of that it costs the same
child care is so expensive
with your child when they're young
rather than having someone else look
after them when we go out to work to pay
some of the cars
[Music]
no no but like we're winning in a
department of like when the day comes
when the little kid says first words
yeah and all and the mother was there
nurturing and she says that oh man do
you mind you must be human
that cuts deep like i just nurtured you
for like extra hours and you're telling
me yes no